à à
anh alo khi xem mọi người
ừ ừ
à Hôm nay thực sự thì à Như tựa đề các
bạn thấy thì mình đang hợp bí bía cũng
không hẳn chẳng qua là
dùng từ là không biết được hôm nay sẽ
nên dạy gì
chỉ còn mình biết là cần phải dậy những
cái gì thì có mình mình đã từng đi dậy
rồi nên hàng ra là dạy rất nhiều thứ rồi
có rất nhiều thứ dậy rồi nhưng mà
Ở đây các bạn thì mình để mình thử kể
cho các bạn với việc dạy ở trên trường
nó sẽ khác nó ngoạn bởi việc chiến
trường là sẽ là ở những cái lúc mà làm
đồ án kiểu này thì đôi khi ở không dậy
gần như là không ít khi dạy thêm kiến
thức mới lắm mà chủ yếu là cho các bạn
lên lên trường để mà làm việc cho nhóm
với nhau cũng như là mình kiểm tra
thường xuyên hàng ngày và kiểu gần như
các bạn chỉ ngồi đấy mà làm lại tiếp tục
ngồi làm cốt thôi chứ chứ không kiểu
dạng là ngày nào cũng học thêm cái đức
mới vì gần như là kiến thức cơ bản để mà
làm được cái đồ ăn một này các bạn đã
biết đủ rồi
ở đây là
mà dậy nhiều quá đôi khi các bạn kiểu
các bạn còn chưa làm theo kịp không ạ mà
lại dạy thêm kiến thức mới thì các bạn
sẽ bị choáng nên là gần như là một tuần
dạy khá là ít rồi đấy làm cho hai tháng
mà nóng hoặc 2 tháng các bạn gần như
ngày nào cũng đến để mà kiểm tra cũng
như là lại tiếp tục ngồi làm việc với
nhau vân vân
thức ăn nhiều sinh viên Mình cảm thấy
khá nhằm chán và kẹo muốn muội muốn ở
nhà làm hơn mất công đến trường nhưng mà
tiểu minh minh cũng mình cũng ép sinh
viên là là phải đến Bởi vì thực ra đi
làm nữa khi các bạn thế các bạn cũng sẽ
nghĩ mình ngồi nhà làm cũng được Tại sao
phải lên công ty Đông ạ
à à
Ừ Ok nhưng mà đại khái mục đích của hôm
nay thì sẽ là mình à mình có mấy câu hỏi
này cho các bạn
mình nhất là thứ bảy mình đã từng nói đó
là
là bây giờ thứ Bảy sẽ là ngày dành cho
đồ án chứ không phải dạy thêm kiến thức
mới nên là ở ngày thứ bảy này mình đang
mình đang định ấy sẽ ra ngày thứ bảy này
sẽ là ngày để mình dạng mình kiểm tra đồ
án các bạn bằng cái livestream trực tiếp
như này và sẽ và chia sẻ màn hình mày
đúng ngọn Thế nên thành ra là các bạn sẽ
thấy được đồ án các bạn khác Trông như
nào gọi là hôm thứ bảy này mình sẽ
livestream chấm bài gần như là thế
thì mình sẽ cho mọi người xem cách chấm
minh là trung hòa bởi vì mình thấy tốn
hơn nhiều thời gian việc chấm bài
nên là dành vào thứ bảy không biết được
các bạn có phản đối với được chia sẻ cái
cái đồ án mình sớm không kiểu gì Các bạn
kiểu gì cũng phải chia sẻ cho mọi người
xem thôi nhưng mà Chỉ là sớm vấn đề gì
không
ừ ừ
Hai và thứ bảy sẽ là nói chung là một
buổi đấy Mình có ghi kia là giao lưu tâm
sự về đoán các bạn thắc mắc bất kỳ cái
gì sẽ hỏi hôm trước có bạn cũng nói với
mình đó là ờ
Ừ anh nên dành một ít thời gian mỗi buổi
để mà có tâm sự cuối buổi tặng giao lưu
tâm sự với các bạn nhiều bạn cũng muốn
có tâm sự trực tiếp hơn là bình luận
mình không biết các bạn thế nào nhưng mà
mình lại sợ do những người bạn mà kiểu
vào mình chỉ học hiện tại vì vì cái tiêu
đề nó là để học mà đúng ạ hàng ra các
bạn đấy mà thấy video mà vẫn hay tiếng
từ ra trong đấy có nửa tiếng dậy chứ
tiếng rưỡi gọi lại tâm sự được ạ Bạn ấy
cũng sẽ bị choáng Nếu không hiểu thì
không nên thực ra tôi hạn chế chưa cả để
cái video mới dài quá
Nếu làm video tầm 2 gần hai tiếng là tôi
phải tắt ngay chứ nếu mà hai tướng xong
ông ông nào mà kiểu
Ừ ok vào bảo học bài không phải dài hơi
buồn giờ hết ế
Anh ở chung là hôm nay tôi thực sự thì
tôi hôm nay tôi sẽ không thấy cái gì mới
mà tôi đấy tôi hỏi mấy hôm nay đó làm
mấy ông có đồng ý duyệt ít nhất là Đoàn
có 40 ông ở đây không biết bố mày ông ở
đây đều cùng làm đồ án hay không nhưng
mà có đồng ý việc của tôi chia sẻ đồ án
sớm các bạn không để mà tôi sẽ thứ bảy
tôi sẽ biến hàng Đê La Thành Thứ Bảy để
mà chấm bài mà và
Em vào xem ở chung nhà
anh Bởi vì không thì tốt cả chủ nhật
ngày chủ nhật của tôi để ngồi chấm bài
mới không mệt vãi
mày hậu sẽ hiểu qua được cái việc áp lực
khi mà khi mà kiểu ngày nào đi dậy xong
rồi đi Cuối tuần đi chấm bài có cùng tôi
hết từ ngày cuối tuần rồi Hôm nay các
bạn hãy cho con muộn Nó ngoan bởi vì
sáng tôi học chiều nó học sáng mại và
chiều mai cũng thế
à Xong rồi tối mai thì tôi chấm bài nữa
cô ấy nói nghe thì
cái cái dại vì đam mê lại công nhận là
đúng rồi đam mê thật vậy Sáng Thằng điên
nào làm việc cuối tuần như thế à
Ê mấy ông trả tôi tiền tôi quyết khám
tội không làm cái việc đấy khi mà nghe
câu đấy mà một phần là tôi là người
không không có chặn tiền bạc nữa nên tôi
càng không
em không có cái lý do gì có thể như kéo
tôi vào đấy ngoài việc đam mê rồi ạ
à à
ờ ờ Thực ra là không hẳn là ba mình nhóm
đâu các bạn sẽ được biết qua là có một
vài nhóm nghỉ rồi thì ra chương trình
cái link của tôi thì các bạn sẽ thấy là
mình có đánh số là những cái nhóm đã nhỉ
Anh cho bạn xem
ở
đây những cái nhóm tự nhiên bay màu như
này thứ cả nhóm nghỉ rồi này
Em hãy không phải nghỉ mà gần như không
liên lạc được chính xác thế không liên
lạc được cái có vào nhóm không liên lạc
được nữa này
chợ hoa cam mình phải tách các nhóm ra
với nhau nữa cũng khá là mệt nói cho tôi
làm tất cả này một mình hết
khó mà có người kiểu trợ giúp cái vụ này
[âm nhạc]
Alo Alo ạ
ờ ờ
vừa rồi shipper gọi mà ok ok
à à
Ồ không Tôi đi Nói thế không phải để
than khăn thân trách phận gì cả cũng cái
này là do mình như nhiều ông bảo là kiểu
mình mình tự rước đến mình tự giữa công
việc vào người thôi mà đúng ạ
anh em tha Nha và tôi sẽ không than rồi
vụ đấy nhưng mà ý thôi là Kiều
khi cây quỹ thời gian của cô ấy một con
người cho dù kiểu muốn cố gắng các thứ
như thế nào ạ nhưng mà Quỹ thời gian của
tất cả mọi người kể cả người giàu người
nghèo chỉ có mỗi 24 giờ đồng ngoại thành
ra là kiểu nó bị
tôi bị thiếu nữa gian hiểu thế
ô tô còn tranh thủ chơi buổi tối buổi
đêm nữa thành ra là tôi toàn dạo này tôi
toàn 23 giờ sáng mới ngủ sau đó sáng lại
phải dậy sớm thì họp nữa cả để học thành
là thứ duy nhất ở đây Tôi đang thiếu đó
thiếu ngủ ngoài thiếu ngủ không phải
thiếu chơi không phải thiếu giải trí
không này thiếu gì cả mày thiếu ngủ nên
thực ra thế nó có hơi có hạt Ý Ừ
nhưng mà để mình muốn làm việc
làm rất nhiều việc mà em thành ra là
mình bị mình đang hơi lạm dụng cái sức
khỏe mình tôi không khuyên mày ông lên
như thế
Ok nhưng mà
nói chung là Tí tôi sẽ chơi tôi sẽ cho
các bạn chơi về cả cá hút nữa mấy các
bạn tra nhìn qua cái hình này các bạn
hình dung được rồi và các bạn nào mà
chơi cao hút rồi thì các bạn sẽ càng có
kinh nghiệm nữa cá vuốt nó kiểu trắc
nghiệm bởi vì à tí thôi cũng phải sửa
lại một tí thôi Tí thôi sẽ tạm mà
em sửa lại một vài phút thì các bạn một
vài phút để tôi mới sửa lại người có hút
ca hút cụ mày có hút cũ tôi từng dạy cho
sinh viên của tôi
để mà cho sinh viên chơi
Xin chào các bạn
kia ngồi ngay vụ có được mình đang định
nói thiệt thứ nhất à cái cái trò cá hút
này nó là trắc nghiệm và các bạn chỉ
chọn một đáp án và
anh có thể có nhiều đáp án đúng à
và ai trả lời nhanh nhất và đúng nhất
thì sẽ sẽ được điểm cao nhất Được điểm
hơn những bạn kia mẹ ăn chị ạ ai trả lời
đúng thì chắc sáng đã có điểm nhưng mà
điện nó sẽ không cao bằng bạn trả lời
nhanh hơn à
em và nó còn thêm gì nhỉ Tự nhiên nếu có
các bạn sẽ nhanh mà sai thứ có gọi không
có điểm nào chưa sẵn rồi đúng ạ
thế Nhưng tôi sẽ có một vài câu mẹ này
nha các bạn nhớ thì chị có hỏi chứ không
phải nhìn câu hỏi rồi Anh đã hoàn nhanh
chết
a nhớ kỹ câu hỏi nói chung mà còn tận
hưởng đấy Thực ra thì tôi luôn hồi nghĩ
đàn no phần thưởng các bạn các bạn cố
gắng rồi Các bạn cũng nên có một cái gì
đó gọi là động viên ấy cho dù nó bé bé
anh to vừa rồi Thôi lần này ra một cái
đó là hồi trước anh hỏi cả các bạn sẽ
được đi cà phê rồi về tôi nhưng xảy ra
nghe Giữ làm gì vậy cậu Giống như mình
người nổi tiếng nhưng mà
em về những cái này mình đã học về Hà
Tĩnh vào lpp đu đủ Đông ạ thì thì bây
giờ phần thưởng sẽ là gì phần thưởng sẽ
là à các bạn sẽ được đi cà phê vậy thôi
Nhưng tôi sẽ bao được anh ăn bao ở đây
bao cho vào cốc nước cái bánh chứ mấy nó
ngoại trừ khi mấy ông rủ đi quán cà phê
sang chảnh thôi nha À lẫn cả những nhưng
mà còn thêm một cái này nữa đó là anh
giống như tôi hứa với bạn à ở trong Đà
Nẵng ấy thì ở trong vòng trong vòng 1
năm 26 tháng gì gì đó miễn là dịch đầu
không cần quá thì tôi sẽ bay vào trong
đấy
nghĩa nghĩa làm chỉ là tôi sẽ Nếu mà các
bạn ở xa đang đang xem ở xã thì tôi sẽ
không hẳn là bay vào đến tất tỉnh các
bạn đâu những con xa quá Mình mình sẽ
nói chung là mình mình chắc phải bay đến
mấy thành phố lớn thôi giống như kiểu
mình có thể bao Sài Gòn này Đà Nẵng này
ở đi đến Hải Phòng ấy mấy cái chỗ thành
phố lớn trả theo mình ở thế không biết
được ở đây của ông nào ạ
em có có màu
đề xuất thêm cái thành phố nào nữa không
thì tôi sẽ cân nhắc
nghe nói chung là tôi đã bay hẳn và lấy
cha cũng sẽ mở offline Hơn nữa
nếu mà dịch bớt căng đúng không ạ sau đó
thì thì ra coi như mình đi du lịch cho
màn không ạ tôi dậy mỹ nam lạnh 10 năm
qua rồi chẳng đi đâu cả thế là tôi muốn
đi thì đi du lịch một tí
A Gọi du lịch sang chảnh thì thôi chứ
thức cái chắc
tôi đến đấy rồi chẳng làm gì đâu gọi là
cây cài tư duy của tôi khi mà đi nghỉ
mát đấy thì đúng kiểu là nghỉ tôi gần
như là thôi ạ
cho
thoải mái ở một cái không gian khác chứ
không phải là
đi tham quan đi hành hạ bản thân đối tôi
nó hành hạ bản thân kia mà các bạn đi
mệt rồi
cái thời gian lúc các bạn đi tàu hay đi
máy bay Mệt tục mà các bạn phải tranh
thủ đi vì chỉ còn 12 ngày nữa lại bay về
các loại có tham quan đồ kiểu các thứ cố
khám phá đủ thứ tôi thế hệ rễ một sự
hành hạ đối tôi nghỉ dưỡng
Ừ nếu mà thực sự các bạn muốn cả bao gồm
cả việc đi khám phá kia ấy các bạn phải
đi du lịch tấm 2 tuần để mà mấy ngày đầu
các bạn Ừ đúng kiểu là xả căng thẳng đi
spa hay nói cho mày đi vui chơi của nó
sẽ cắm thẳng sau đó các bạn mới đi leo
núi hay đi kiểu nó cũng đi khám phá đủ
thời gian này các bạn chán luôn cả Nơi
Đấy nó phải hay tồn chứ nếu mà các bạn
đi trong vòng 23 ngày mà các bạn khám
phá hết các thứ hư đấy đi hành xác như
vậy đi nghỉ dưỡng để quan điểm của tôi
như thế
anh cho biết mấy bạn thế nào nhưng việc
đi mấy cái kiểu tua nhanh nữa hai ba
ngày như thế Tôi thấy mệt đó
Ừ ok lan man quá nghỉ tranh thủ lúc các
bạn đang không nói gì Tôi xin phép tôi à
Sửa lại các bạn nhớ Bây giờ chuẩn bị on
máy tính đi đúng không ạ Có máy tính
theo điện thoại cũng được nhưng mình
khuyên là nên on cái gì kiểu dễ thao tác
tí thôi sẽ chia sẻ hiển thị câu hỏi thế
này các bạn sẽ bấm vào câu trả lời chỉ
cần bấm mà api bấm và màu này bằng một
màu thôi nó không có hiển thị đáp án ở
trên cái màu ở đâu nhé Chỉ có một màu
thôi này ra lại các bạn phải nhìn màn
hình của tôi để bấm mà tôi sẽ phải chỉnh
lại thời gian tầm 1 phút đi để cho các
bạn làm việc thoải mái câu nào thành 1
phút đi chứ không thì livestream của tôi
có độ trễ tôi lại tua nhanh quá hay gì
đó thì các bạn lại bị kiểu bị lỡ nóng
lạnh
ừ ừ
em đứng yên làm một phút đấy nếu mà các
bạn trả lời xong hết rồi thì nó sẽ tự
động nó sẽ tự động nhảy sang chỗ khác
thôi
anh đã nói chung à Bây giờ mà giật tôi k
hút của tôi ý nó sẽ có thật máy mấy cái
ca hút liền cơ ở đấy tôi làm cho HTML
riêng ở tp riêng ở Thanh Vân thì
Ừ thế thế nên là nếu mà một ông nào mà
cậu nói chung là tôi sẽ chơi giải ừ
con gà có tận nhất nhì ba đấy
để tôi xem lại đã
em chẳng lẽ khao luôn cả bao nhất nhì ba
xong nó gì bây giờ mà chưa có hút trận
34 cái Sẽ Ra Sao tập 12 ông ạ
Anh
nghe rồi cũng được không phải nói
Ừ ok cái cái đấy tôi
chúng tôi chấp nhận Nghĩa là bà à Ông
nhất nhì ba thì sẽ có gì nhắn nhắn tin
rồi sau nhé Có thể qua inbox
à đ.m đề mà nhẫn dài sau nhé
a12 ông 12 tỉnh xin thầy phố lại còn ơi
đi du lịch không không Điên à Tôi không
đi được kiến thức này hay tỉnh có về Em
vừa bảo rồi mà Thì
ừ ừ
Em đỡ có gì cơ
phụ
nữ có con cái bạn gái quan trọng gì đó
à à
ừ ừ
Ừ đợi tí tôi mấy ông có gì nhắn tin tâm
sự thì cứ nhắn nhất tôi tôi sẽ phép tôi
sửa lại mày có hỏi phát đã sửa không
Những sữa câu hỏi còn phải sửa lại cái á
Ê thằng ngu si quá bấm mà hơi khó để mà
sửa
ở ngọn cái này nhược điểm này nó không
cho Bấm vào thể để mà nhảy sang
thời trang mới
à à
ừ ừ
thì các bạn đợi thông tí
Em hãy ở tôi sẽ hỏi về Nói chung nhà thì
ở các bạn à
khi truy cập cá Hut chi mit và đội Mỹ
livestream
câu hỏi
em
về
Amway
HCl
CS Java Script
mạnh TP ê
à à
à à giải Đổi loại tài liệu
thực ra là mình vừa nãy mình có nghĩ
việc đấy Nhắn Thực ra về sau mình bảo
rồi mình sẽ kiểu gì mình sẽ chia sẻ tài
liệu cho các bạn đây là không Mình nghĩa
không cần phải dùng cái đấy làm
giả làm gì cả kiểu gì về sau mình sẽ
mình để tài liệu cho riêng mình làm gì
đâu đúng không ạ Mình sẽ kiểu gì mình sẽ
ra mình mua rồi mình sẽ chia sẻ các bạn
Ha ha đời ít ra để đấy làm cái giải của
bên A
bên đồ án này bên đồ này khi mà thành
công thì khi bảo vệ bảo vệ ổn thế thì sẽ
được
Em thích mình tí thực đam mới câu hỏi
mình mình của mình dậy hồi trước phải
đang hơi bị thiên hướng với theo từng
lớp này nha nó mới khó
Ừ ok một cái đứa này
lý
giải được ôm tôi
thì tại sao ngoại muốn ôm tôi nhé
à à
vi
phạm thế tôi có câu hỏi về tôi có câu
hỏi về bên A you tìm đấy mì đâu nha
Không biết là mấy ông cổ hứng thú làm
lại tôi có hỏi không ra có ông ở đây đi
Online đưa tin con bị đi rồi
ừ ừ
à à
Ừ Mày sợ chưa nha bây bây giờ chưa trước
được
được mặc áo tôi lỡ phải tao à
ạ
bây bây giờ chơi trước về like có rách
quên lại người ta sửa lại có ghi khách
nhé
i keep automa Tôi làm gì gấu kia tôi
đang dùng edu
ờ ờ
Ừ đúng ạ Chúng ta sẽ chơi
em gái
à à
thì chị ngồi à
a classic Mode không có tin gì cả
có một tí nữa
ê ê
Sau
đó các bạn bây giờ sẽ
Ừ cái này là
chờ đợi mình một tí cái này là hiển thị
tên của người cũ mất rồi
anh Đợi mình tí nhé Tại mình tính mình
không muốn đi đổi tên người cũ
em
không có chơi mới à Mask
à à
Ê thằng hoa nhài Nói chung là nó bây giờ
mình đang dùng là miễn phí không biết là
do mình dùng miễn phí hay gì cả nhưng mà
Ừ nó kiểu bây giờ rất khó để dùng mình
thấy thế
áo kiểu bây giờ nó thêm một tấm thứ khó
dùng vãi bữa trước dùng đơn giản bấm vào
chơi cứ ra xong bây giờ Nó kiểu nó cứ
lằng nhằng ấy ý
à à
thì các bạn lên DK hút chậm máy đi chơi
nhỉ Chuẩn bị nhé
ừ ừ
à à
ở
đại ca hút này Bây giờ nó bắt trả phí
ông ơi Ừ nó bắt chảo phí rồi
xe lửa
ông bắt trả phí à năm đô cho
Ê mày lên 100 người còn không thì chỉ 10
người tớ xem nữa hình như vừa rồi nó bảo
cho miễn phí dùng thử để tôi thử phát
mình chúng ta chỉ cần thử trong ngày hôm
nay thôi
Ừ đợi thông tin nhé
ở đó người dùng treo rồi
ở HP nó không đề xuất dùng thử này bình
tĩnh tĩnh à
à à
ừ ừ
vì nó không hỏi cái vụ cháy Ô đã thế nhỉ
À
à à
ừ ừ
thế này đây để tôi
Ừ từ tự
à à
sẽ được miễn phí 7 ngày
Ừ tí thôi Tí mấy ông Nhắc tôi là tôi ờ ờ
ờ
đi
tìm em nhé tôi để tối hủy cái này nhé
không mất tiền đấy
I Bet You thể bỏ qua
ừ ừ
à à
anh nói tôi mụn mua cái dùng thử rồi
điền đầy đủ thông tin nhắn thử thôi ok
Nói chung là bây giờ
ở biệt thự thủ chơi phát nhạc
à à
a game Arsenal
ca nhạc Giáng Sinh nhạc cửa sổ âm nhạc
giáng sinh à
Em à bây giờ có hiển thị câu hỏi và câu
trả lời ở trên máy người dùng nữa rồi
này được đỡ khó chịu nữa
á hậu nhiên làn đổi Model answer
ừ ừ
I
thought Automatic mùa thu actions
A weird không ạ
em chuyển hôi chuyện thôi
Ừ thôi Cho hỏi nói chơi trò chơi tận 95
ông on này xuất sắc lấy ông có này
à à
anh em bấm vào đây để mà nào
a cho mấy ông à
a cho mấy ông hai phút
tôi tôi vẫn chưa sửa được số thời gian
sống thời gian của một câu hỏi đâu thế
nên chỉ 20 giây thôi nhá Mấy ông Chịu
khó trả lời nhanh nhé bây giờ nhưng mà
bây giờ tôi vừa sửa được đó là Hiển thị
có hỏi ở trên màn hình của mấy ông rồi
Anh thành ra là
Ừ thế thế nên là mấy ông nhà
mày ông cứ xem rồi trả lời luôn không
còn nhìn màn hình tôi nữa cơ chị nói cho
tôi chỉ quan tâm mày việc là xem ông nào
được điểm cao thôi
em
thấy Long bu2i
ông đừng có
để tên tục nhé để tiếp tục và tôi có nút
xóa rồi đấy tôi cho bảy màu không ấy
Nhưng mà ông cứ cẩn thận
nhà bao việc OK
còn một phút cho mẹ à Cái này về rách
nhá á
anh
hỏi vợ lên nói chơi bời đấy lên hẳn hơn
100 ôm 100 Ông nội tôi vừa rồi tôi chọn
cái bản rẻ tiền đội rẻ tiền nhất size
giày thứ nhất nên anh ra là chỉ tối đa
được 100 người rồi nhá ông phải không
lên màu trắng Năm Ông đi
không không vào được đâu
anh kể về Jack như một ai đó à bật mí
một tí đó sim sinh viên đầu tiên à Thôi
trò cho đầu tiên tôi dậy
Ê
tôi dậy bạn đấy cũng là về nơi khách
Vì vậy bây giờ lên livestream lên 114
mấy uống hết à
để uống chia sẻ gì đó đúng không Chứ ở
Ừ nếu không đi
chơi với nhiều à
từ cái cho họ cho đầu tiên tôi dậy cũng
phải về đích mà bạn đầy ra cũng có ở đây
bạn đấy cũng sẽ tham gia bảo vệ đoán
cùng mấy ông ấy mấy ông ấy sau sẽ đoán
được là ai
bạn đấy Đúng là một cao thủ rồi mẹ tội
không lo bạn ấy lắm à
Anh kênh anh Toàn ấy 3 phần anh thương
ấy Ok 70 ông Tạm chốt nhé
hi vọng không lag gì cả cái này nó Tôi
không biết được mà mày không bị văng ra
thì thế nào nên em mấy ông cứ giữ Nói
chung là cái đường chuyền của tôi không
bị ảnh hưởng đường trường tôi bị ảnh
hưởng không liên quan đến của ông đó nhá
thì ra mấy ông ở chung một đường chuyện
mà đều hay gì gì đó mới bị bong ra thì
mai tốt và là việc của mấy ông nhé
Ok bắt đầu là
chuyện thôi
ừ ừ
à à
Ê mấy ông thấy có vấn đề gì thì bảo tôi
luôn nhá
là tôi để 60 giây rồi sẽ đi thoải mái
không ạ Tôi Không nhớ Hồi đấy tôi để bà
như vậy nữa
ừ ừ
à à
à à ừ ừ
Ừ có gì đâu mà lỗ Ô em đơn giản mà
U60 60 Giây có vẻ hơi dài sau bao nhiêu
không
à à
ừ ừ
a38 không trả lời đúng cũng được
Ừ ok nhà bao việc điểm cà phê
khi vk
VCK trả lời rất nhanh ok không biết bạn
ơi bạn nào
ừ ừ
Anh
nhớ nhớ Để ý kỹ nha Tôi có mấy cái lừa
đấy thì không nhanh quá đừng chỉ rồi đấy
ạ
anh
không chơi một ông hai máy nhé Mùa Đông
2 máy thì đôi khi cũng không biết được
nó đúng đó sai em ạ ạ
a vẫn nhiều âm trả lời đúng phết nhỉ Nhớ
Giận 2 Ừ hai cái đúng mà luôn quá nhiều
người Đúng Ok cái chứ cái gạch bên này
nó là đi get nó sống á á
Lê
Hữu Lâm đã lên gần đâu hay loa kể thế
thôi I
ừ ừ
A Gọi nhân đôi điểm này à
à à
cho tôi trò tận 90 giây ông ạ này để ý
kĩ nhá ngồi gạch 10 hội thế à
ừ ừ
ờ ờ
[âm nhạc]
ừ ừ
chủ đề đề mà nhanh quá bị tắt thì chả
bạn xem trên livestream mình thôi ông ạ
Mình không biết nó hiển thị là như nào
luôn à
[âm nhạc]
ừ ừ
300 Để đôi khí với máy khác nhau Nó còn
hiển thị khác nhau đấy Mình nghĩ hết
Vì vậy nếu dùng điện thoại có thể là sẽ
nhận khác
ừ ừ
à à
A vẫn có nhiều ông già Đúng vé đúng
Ê mày cái câu này tôi chữa rồi chồng ạ
có 2 loa lên đâu rồi
Ừ kệ data sim lên tôi
ở lại công nhân 2
ừ ừ
à à
số 90 giây nha Để kỹ nha à
ở tuổi 90 giây mà ông vào nhanh như Chớp
ừ ừ
[Vỗ tay]
em
chỉ mấy giây đổ mày ông vào đấy 101 để
làm đủ thứ đấy à
ừ ừ
à à
U17 ông giở đúng à
anh xem lại nhé
Ừ cái nó bắt buộc phải có phải ở chấm mà
Mấy ông chọn như thế em không có phải
không có chấm gì sai là thôi mà sau này
chuyển một số rồi Anh phải nghe là không
được Có số 0 đằng này không ạ
áo cặp đôi điểm khác nhiều lật kèo thật
kể
chi tiết
ừ ừ
ở
nhà ông tỉnh phết nhỉ à
Ừ ok
lê hiếu động lên à
cô tiên nha
em còn hai câu em cố lên
Ê công nghệ dễ
ừ ừ
Ê
công nghệ
bị thời gian hơi lâu Ông ơi để thời gian
lâu
lâu cho các bạn thoải mái
vừa nãy vào đông lắm mà bây giờ chỉ có
mỗi chồng mấy bạn ạ
à à
anh nghe đáp án nói lên tất cả rồi đúng
không ạ tôi không giải thích yêu
Ê nói cô ấy I
à à
ừ ừ
Ừ
ông nào mà trả lời được câu trước mặt
trời câu này nghỉ nhé á
ừ ừ
nó dễ mà à
ở nhóm chỉ cần đủ kiến thức là đủ
ừ ừ
à à
các tổ chức trở lại ở đây
ông được rồi à
Ừ ok sẵn sàng chưa xem xem ai làm bảng
vào nhé
A Gọi 797 luôn chơi cho vui
cũng vậy trên vậy Hữu lập anh cũng 7/7
mấy ngoài lừa rồi Thế là lừa rồi
khi
truyền hình
truyền hình gì đấy
Ừ Thôi nghỉ chơi ba bạn đầu đó nhá Top 5
kệ nhá Ok bỏ qua trong năm
với tôi có tận 5 cái cao hút cơ rồi
hai bạn hạnh phúc chưa bây giờ tiếp nhá
33 bạn anh mà không ngờ Nhắn tin nữa tôi
là thiệt cho mày ông ấy nhá ạ
số trực tiếp
ạ bây giờ sẽ đến cái à dễ hơn ví HTML
em hết em à Lồ mà Mấy ông không làm được
tối chị nhé
à à
ừ ừ
vì thời buổi đến làm đồ ăn đến nơi rồi
mày không không biết HTML là tội không
không biết phải nói gì đâu nhé
ừ ừ
anh
à Mất nóc nhà Tôi muốn chơi cùng các bạn
cho bạn để biết
cho biết thế nào là sinh viên mà rồi đấy
không học hành của tôi cái gì đâu buồn
lắm mẹ tao ngồi trên nhân phẩm Vĩnh cạnh
thôi bạn muốn thử chơi bạn kia là HP pro
dễ mà mày ông chứng minh bạn ơi điều đấy
thì ra đi
Ờ cái này mình không nhớ đã giảm thời
gian chưa đâu
Nói chung là cái này mình làm nấu lắm
rồi phải hai ba năm trước rồi nên là
thằng em mình không nhớ không nhớ thời
gian của từng cái đâu như có cái nó sẽ
hai máy dậy có đấy ạ
anh mãi chưa vào Đợi tí lại vào rồi mình
vào nhé
anh cũng Trường 100 người mà ngọn 100
người tôi tôi chỉ giới hạn 100 người
thôi không ạ
à à
về cơ cấu Tôi muốn cơ cấu Nhưng cái này
là cốt người khác mà Cốt bản thân mình
cơ cấu không ạ
vụ
ánđối nhiên là vẫn có thể có cái xanh
đáp án của tôi nhưng mà bạn đấy Có biết
gì đâu bạn tôi đã bảo rồi Bạn ấy gái to
như thế thì chỉ tại sao lại cho bạn ấy
ra vào đúng không ạ để cho bạn ấy gái
xem tí bạn để alo alo được không ạ
số
120 người đang xem tôi ạ mày không đồ
rồi à Thế bây giờ rồi à
ừ ừ
anh
nói chưa
Ok Rồi bắt đầu nhá lại vào rồi
93 người rồi ok
đâu ông nào đã tên vậy bạn
cục cưng kute kể
thêm quá quà của tôi có mùi cái cà phê
hết Ông mà thêm là cái gì Đúng rồi only
see tội đưa Thế onishi à
ở top 1 ở đường tới khao đi cà phê
a hpm rồi nhá dễ vãi chưởng ấy ạ mày
không trả lời buồn lắm
ừ ừ
Vì
thế mới có phải đâu giờ sai tao buồn mày
Ông cứ buồn mày lắm chị ạ anh không biết
nói gì
ừ ừ
Ừ
vợ chả nhớ cô ấy đã bạn là gì đó thật có
khi ở Tôi cho cô ấy đã là là gì gì không
nhớ lắm à
à à Đúng nó đã đúng
A kojc có gì không đó lại chẳng nó gì cả
hôm
nay tại sao bị như thế bởi vì Tuy là nằm
trong hết à Nhưng mà
anh theo hotel chuẩn của nó không đúng
nhưng mà nó vẫn hiển thị ra như bình
thường thôi nó vẫn hiển thị toàn yêu
thương à
ừ ừ
thì
các bạn đừng quan tâm người cái đi lấy
nhìn Lysine thì có nhưng mà còn nữa con
cho các bạn thì tốc độ theo thời gian
thực mạnh ở
à à
Anh Huy vẫn có 70 trả lời sai được mẹ
tôi buồn lắm
à à
từ
20 giây của nhanh quá
thì ra chỉ cần 23 giây quyết đoán ở được
rồi 20g là quá nhiều luôn à
ừ ừ
Ừ ok tiếp nha
à à
à
cô lại khối người chết này à
nụ
cười khối người chết tại sao sai Ờ
Các bạn nhớ về uli ạ ul ol nhân thực ra
thể đánh sách còn một loại nữa còn một
loại nữa ông nào tra thêm cái loại nữa
thì sẽ biết tôi không dậy loại đấy Tôi
không thấy lại đấy Gửi lại để gần như
không bờ không ở dùng nhưng mà còn thêm
loại nữa
Đúng rồi nó để chờ nó description liz
ý nghĩa ở chứng tỏ những ông là không
học của tôi họ và tìm hiểu thêm thì lại
xảy câu này
ừ ừ
Anh xin lỗi xin lỗi tôi bảo có con lừa
mà nó không ạ phải có một câu ở đó Lừa
đấy chứ
10 điểm mà không trả lời được
à à à không không điểm trả lời đúng
không điểm á bởi vì ở đây đây là chị
biết thêm cái nước thôi Hình như là lần
đấy tôi không cho mày không điểm không
thiên vị quá
không Sao không dám
ai biết cho vui thôi ạ
ở Cộng hòa may mắn ở được câu này thì
rất là ăn may thôi
ừ ừ
Ừ tôi lừa nhưng mà tôi không nhẫn tâm
chưa điểm ấy ông ấy không ạ thì cho ông
mất chuỗi
mất chỗ ít hàng thôi à
Nghe câu này lại một câu mới nữa này tôi
không biết có mày có thấy điện mày không
những câu nói một câu giữa Mời à
cha mẹ ông không đoán được đúng không ạ
Có thằng 10 cái thẻ con cơ
Ừ nhưng mà câu này cũng Hình như là tôi
nhờ không làm cũng cho 0 điểm thôi
37 bây giờ mì Ông sai thì phải ông sẽ
nhớ được thì nước ngài đúng không ạ
mà tại sao có mưa Nếu ông cha đã V3
School ở sẽ ra tổng 10 cái thẻ thẻ đấy
anh không ai được không biết đâu
em coi nhanh hay này chắc rằng có điểm
ừ nhanh nhanh nhanh nhanh nhanh nhanh
ừ ừ
anh không hỏi chọn xs max đấy à
họ đậu xanh Tôi có cái thống kê đấy nhá
tôi xem được tí xem được ba ông nào cho
đi em mắc đi nhá Ừ
anh ạ
chị sẽ bước lang lại để mở tao mời đúng
không phải gạch dưới Tab
sữa non ăn có phải ông vượt lên rồi
ừ ừ
Ừ đúng rồi các bạn phải ghi đầy đủ như
thế này không ạ thuộc lắm à
ô
ồ nay tôi nói rồi
ở
tinh hoàn có phải bạn bị khó thở do mạng
các bạn đấy Nên là các bạn phải
xem xét lại mạnh các bạn thôi
U22 ta mà lúc mẹ đúng
nghe Danh Hài những giây phút cuối nhân
Ừ
thế 19 chết bà luôn à
ở trên giờ không đồng ý kỹ câu hỏi à alo
em đọc lại câu hỏi đọc lại câu hỏi nó
thể hủy thẻ văn bản không phải là
ở thẻ chủ chiến xuống dòng thẻ văn bản
chiến xuống dòng
a cho tôi Tôi đã nói sẽ chẳng có lừa rồi
mày giờ Mày không nghĩ con này dễ thế á
Alo
chứ không phải chơi hết Cậu ơi tính điểm
ấy nhé coi tính tiền đấy nhé
à à
trò
chơi chơi mà không lừa điện thoại dễ quá
nó không tạo sự đột biến tính à
à à
ừ ừ
I Pray có hai ông sai là hai đã làm sai
đấy ạ
A M là điểm cafe à ở câu cuối Ý
anh
nói bấm nhắc mãi
tôi hệ rõ ràng mấy ông
mày cũng không đọc có hỏi đúng không ạ ạ
Ừ
ok sẵn làm chưa
ở sân hàng chưa xem nhé
có người trả lời 10 10 trên bậy bạ không
còn đúng Tuyệt đối được nữa sẽ không để
đúng Tuyệt đối được nữa
ở ngoài có bạn vừa lên này một bạn với
lên đó là còn thợ thằng câm ok
Ừ
nếu lấy hạnh phúc kia
hát tmg đấy nhá mày Ông đừng nghĩ HTML
là dễ đúng không ạ Có ai trả lời được
hết đúng đúng không
e47
không thể nhớ
mày lắm hả gì đấy bột mấy năm mấy OK
quán nửa mà
mình bảo ở Hà Tĩnh vào rẽ không dễ làm
dễ thì nào pp nó dễ đấy hồi nãy tôi pp
này tôi cho kia mới học nó dễ
anh chị nhà Túc top 4 mấy năm ấy à
ừ ừ
à à
Ừ cái nó không cho Đăng nhập nhấn này ra
là các bạn cứ mỗi lần vào lại thì lại
phải đi lại tên cho trải nghiệm này hơi
không tốt
Uh cho nó lưu lợi Cookie cùng người dùng
kiểu tên cũng thì nó hay hơn
em
chưa học môn này á Ôi tí rồi còn có
atwell cơ bản này quen nâng cao xem xem
mà không trả lời được không
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
khi
con thể là con lỡ
bắt đầu nhé
80 bắt đầu nhá Ừ
cb150 người xem điều đấy
Ở đâu đấy Mày không rủ bạn không gọi
cùng với vỡ à
thôi Chỉ thế
bộ báo động a90 rồi cơ à
ở trên thôi
a90 nốt mà không lấy nữa rồi chuyện vậy
anh ạ
a p p là này dễ cực
Ừ
cái này đúng kiến thức mới học luôn
Xin mời vào công nhân hai đứa
không phải không làm được nghỉ nghỉ luôn
không không học cái p.bình nữa nhỉ mịn
ừ ừ
có
những loại bạn đấy người đã lóc
Khi nào ông ạ onishi câu này phát nào ạ
ừ ừ
à à
U21 ông Nóc Nhà Xanh ơi câu đầu tiên rồi
đúng không học của mình đó các em
Anh quay điểm giống nhau thế à
ừ ừ
ở
buổi cái này là tôi nhắc đi nhắc lại bao
lần không biết nữa cái
cái này rồi
hilesi thật à à
ừ ừ
Ừ mẹ viết theo đúng thứ tự nhá nhiều nhé
viết tắt theo đúng thứ tự là gì nó không
lửa sau này tôi không lửa
à à
Lê
Ngọc
Bảo Ngọc a
à à
anh
ở tôi để ra đồng nữa nhé tớ để ra đô mẽ
nóng mà vào c2b gì đó xuống biết rồi tối
để mọi thứ tôi để nó sặc cháo lại cái
cái
thứ tự của câu trả lời này là
có một ông nhanh tay hơn đã lên dẫn chưa
sau
khi ông chết rồi đấy à Tôi không dạy mày
Ông shopee mày ông không chết được bạn
xem đi rồi à
cách làm mồi câu không dậy mấy ông xem
pin không có local port 8080 nữa ừ ừ có
khi câu này dễ rồi mày không
tôi dậy mà ông la con mà
không Chứ sinh viên tôi dậy shopee sẽ có
thêm phải ghi thêm cộng 80 80 nữa
ông đi C và hai đầu thôi à
ở
trong công hàng nhiều sinh viên nó chết
hơn
Ừ
ông ảo không bấm bị đậu đợi lâu quá vẫn
có tám 22 ông Hường chết kiểu này á Tôi
hơi ngạc nhiên đấy
Ừ cái kia là cổng nhé nó chả liên quan
gì cả nó là cổng thôi
sự
truyền hình
di truyền hình liên thiên
Ừ thôi không đi chết tên bạn đấy
ừ ừ
ở tp dùng shopee hoặc là bao gồm mình
khuyên các bạn dùng Dragon hơn sample
lầm lỗi Vâng ạ
ừ ừ
I only see I
à à
Ừ cái này mình có để ngẫu nhiên thật
ngẫu nhiên câu trả lời Không nhớ thì
thôi phải xem
à à
ý nghĩ như có một ông vào rồi ông ấy che
mái bây giờ là điều tất cả 86 còn lại
phải đỡ Ông ấy
không trách được
số 87 không ạ Vậy chưa
Ừ cái ký hiệu trụy này vẫn đúng nhá
thì các bạn chưa giờ được dùng thôi ký
hiệu chỗ này vẫn đúng
Ừ cái này vừa lấy vợ nó làm ảnh mà miếu
vẫn khoa người được thôi chịu người ông
ấy thế này giờ rồi Thế là đúng kiểu vào
cho vui rồi
ừ ừ
Ê
thằng kia thì ra quy tụ nhiều hơn nhưng
mà cái đấy vẫn là chỗ ở bên wp được trả
qua mày Dung thôi
Khi
nào ông là chọn xe đưa ra mà sợ nó
phải đáp án Chắc bây giờ
chồng mày đúng đúng
đúng rồi Cái này không liên quan TP thật
Mình nhầm đấy
À đúng rồi bởi vì hôm đấy mình dậy xong
cho sinh viên về kể lại mình áp dụng
luôn
khi
mình bị nhầm đấy thơm sao
thỉnh thoảng ôn lại thì kiến thức tí
cái này dễ mà
Anh tên là tốt một nhở cấp 42
Anh ở ngoài đó tên gì đây hư hỏng thế
ừ ừ
Ừ cái vừa nãy nói rồi
nói phát nữa xem nào ạ
Thế
là quyết Ừ anh mới xem lại hình như là
anh chưa làm cá hút ra quýt nên là hai
cái sau rồi giờ chỉ ở aquare về cái kia
nâng cao thôi nên là
không biết thế nào
Anh xem lại phát nữa ngồi đấy tôi đấy
Chẳng hiểu sai rồi không làm nó giá ship
cả à
a
Xuki câu này nhanh nha
nếu không trả lời chồng á
Thôi có gì ở đàn đo nhé ạ
khi hack ra 7 cũ đúng liên tiếp ghê ghê
có quấy chua phone X2
Cho xem bằng 7 Cầu xã Đồng liên tiếp
được nữa không
chú phone thì trả lời nhanh mà
đúng hơn
à à
Ừ tôi có chạy mấy ông Pascal đâu mà hỏi
với Pascal con lừa thôi
à à
ừ ừ
mở mở mở mở máy mở máy copy code chạy
thẳng luôn em được không nhanh nhanh
nhanh
những câu hỏi dễ kiếm nó vài ông bị bật
tốt đấy
ê ê
ừ ừ
à à
ô ồ Lặng Yên chưa Wen 111 trong e queo
nó vẫn hiểu là Chu nên nó vẫn chạy bé
với mẹ queo thôi mà nó qua server được
không nhưng mà hồi mà tôi dậy đây là môn
p nên mình sẽ dậy mà em quê ở trong chạy
qua server là thế kết quả đó là
Cho xem ông nào 8.8 luôn được 23 Ok
ừ ừ
Ừ ông thứ ba 8.810 Ông còn lại toàn trên
toàn thôi
[âm nhạc]
ở top Nam
ở top 5 những không có thưởng gì đó
thưởng thưởng danh dự thôi
thì ra các bạn vẫn thể gạt mình đi cà
phê được nhưng mỗi tội mình không trả
tiền các bạn đâu
ok
rồi Tiếp nha Tí còn hai ngày nữa hai cái
sau khó kinh khủng nên là không biết là
các bạn còn hào hứng không
anh em mình rõ ràng chọn là đun kiểu sắp
xếp lại câu trả lời mà nên là mấy ông
bảo ôn đi Share rồi sẽ là nó linh tinh
đấy nhá á
ở top được chi không ạ ngày vào muộn
đúng không thấy có chơi mới và đúng
không
à à
ở top top 3 thì sẽ được tôi sao cà phê à
[âm nhạc]
À hôm nay quả bóng đá thế mày Ô ngon ghê
đấy
nó lừa rồi
ừ ừ
à à
ở KS Woa cơ bản này nhá Ừ
ừ ừ
anh
ra còn mấy cái câu hỏi về pp nữa cơ
nhưng mà của đo sự do tôi dậy sinh viên
tôi nên không nhớ nó Nó kiểu chú trọng
bên sinh viên hơn nhà thôi Mình cứ tạm
thêm hai cái đỡ mình kết thúc bữa hôm
nay cũng được
hả mình còn chưa trả lời câu hỏi ở đây
cơ nó cả tâm sự nữa trả cuối buổi mình
tâm sự thêm một tí rồi mình nghỉ Bữa hôm
mạng được Hôm nay đi chơi vui vẻ giao
lưu mà nóng bạn vui vẻ thôi
à à
anh Linh Ngọc Đàm à
ô ô là tên đôi này bình tĩnh
I only see Hồi trước tôi đạt Solic thật
rồi tôi phải phanh những cái đáp án khác
k yêu ấy
I Pray to win play fun nhãn Rỡ
I only you ok lêu lêu đồ FA Ok
Ừ rồi
đi bán rồi nha
thôi I
anh trai của câu lạc bộ rồi
ở
chỗ này khoa nhanh hết
nó kết bạn nha à
[âm nhạc]
ở
khách sạn không giống hệt rồi mình cứ
giống hệt chứ hả Nó không Không chạy
giống hiểu không ạ là phải có khác đi
không ấy Nó Gộp chung lại một tuần nữa
à à
Ừ
tối em qua em cơ bản
cơ bản mà nó hoặc các bạn thấy ngàn
không Câu này dễ à
Ừ đúng rồi mọi người ăn nhanh à ở tốc độ
ban thờ
em bận mãn cuộc đời
trước cục tay ok
A
Gọi bấm nhanh hẹn giờ rồi à
Ừ ừ
lừa
[Tiếng cười]
mày không nhận ra tại sao Say chưa
có rất nhiều sinh viên Tôi bị gì này mà
trả lời sai với anh nữa à
thế này thì bấm nhanh này tôi cố tình
đấy tôi cho mấy câu dễ hiểu trước cái
cảm thấy phải bấm nhanh mà nhanh rồi
không thấy cậu lại bấm nhanh hết sức có
thể tôi chết đó
vì
thế mà vẫn mập nhanh nó cũng đùa tôi à
không rút kinh nghiệm gì cả
Không biết kinh nghiệm mà dở rồi
update làm gì có form đâu Alo Anh Chỉ Có
Xe Black và Delete thì mới lấy dữ liệu
ra để mà về mà sợ để mà cậu xóa nó đi họ
lấy ra thôi
ông ngoại update là người có phong đâu
Ơ kìa Ơ kìa Tại sao Tại sao thế nhỉ
ở trại đừng có trách đâu rồi nhá trách
mấy ông rồi
khi tôi vừa nói là rút kinh nghiệm không
mấy ông có rút kinh nghiệm đâu Nếu không
tôi đã cảnh báo trước thì ở nhà đúng
không
chỉ mong một lần có một là tên anh
tin nhắn hay này
anh
vẫn ngày
mấy ông chẳng biết rút kinh nghiệm của
các vị
ngồi nhiều ngồi nhìn ông này cười bên
hoa trong cái lắm Anh
của rồi xong rồi không cần cả à
Ừ ừ vậy rồi không lừa gì cả Bây giờ lại
đúng à
à à
ừ ừ
anh
nói bấm nhanh mãi được
bữa nay
nó nhà bà coi size nghỉ chơi
Hà
Nội dễ mà
Mấy ông bị sao ấy có thể tôi trả lời đó
tôi thật mà
em coi rất bình thường có thể trở có cái
gì cả mấy Tại sao mày không trả phố nhỉ
em học bài Fly Ngồi dễ mà
cho tôi rất bình thường nó chả có cái gì
cả Sao có tên tôi hay sai đúng không
không không lại còn chẳng có dấu nhé tên
rỡ bình thường chẳng có dấu cả
à à
tí nữa cái từ đã học nha tôi dậy người
ông thật đấy
mẹ hỏi cho là gì nữa không biết trả lời
rồi nha À
con gà ở tôi nói đã học tất cả tôi vẫn
thêm cái cho chắc chắn đúng nó cả hai lá
và đúng mấy ông mà chọn kiểu đáp án 1,2
rất là sai rồi
ở câu cuối câu cuối câu muối
phụ
nữ ngoài Hình như là không được những kỷ
niệm cơm bỗng nhắc trước thôi à
Ừ rồi
Cho xem kết quả were Bởi vì nó có cấu
trúc nên nó lương để kiểm tra lại dữ
liệu cái sự xứ còn nói với em kiểm tra
gì cả nó luôn nhanh hơn thế thôi
vì vậy ông ấy đúng giá như đám này không
bị lừa đấy bố mẹ ông ai đều không bị lừa
đấy đúng không ạ
[âm nhạc]
I the fog
mountain
[Tiếng cười]
high đi Không biết nói gì
không xa là sai Có những người đúng hết
đây này trả lời sai Nếu người biện hộ
được việc là câu rơ lưỡi không sai là
sai đúng ạ ạ
à Còn một cái esselunga
mấy cái ông vào để cập nhật được Kiểu
nào vậy cho vui thế là nó nhìn thấy cậu
lại Biết tắt này luôn nha nó rồi
Các bạn có thể giao lưu tâm sự một tí
nữa rồi chúng ta nghỉ à
101 đặt tên này có kia không nghĩ mình
được có một đâu
em ngồi vui ở chính quan trọng gì
ừ ừ
à à
ở Lâu Đài Tình Ái
ừ ừ
cô bạn kia lại để tôi pin rồi
cho tôi địt cô giáo
yêu Linh
cả hai ông để tên mã pin rồi Mấy ông để
tên như thế này thì tí Mấy ông không
biết sắc xác nhận kiểu gì
ông của Tú vì vậy vợ bình thường mà vỡ
hàng thôi tôi đã cảnh báo trước cho mấy
ông ngồi thì có gì ở bị móm ạ Nếu không
tự lừa dối bản thân ông thôi
chả bị cao tốt hai lần nữa Hãy chuyện
bình thường với bạn Bạn cảm giác vui
nhất là khi mà lúc đầu không hỏi chấm
tốt vì sao Bứt Phá lên mình tốt với anh
cảm giác mãn nguyện nhé không Nói tên
luôn cả tiền tôi kia
cái này ép gồm nâng cao Á đến đây là
có thể có nhiều người cũng không chạy
được nên là mình lại chơi trò may rủi
thôi ông anh đây thôi mà may mắn thì ăn
ngon anh ạ
a
z nhiều cũ hay
ông cây cối nỗi phải vào đây Đang cái
này sao
cho bạn biết
bạn là tiếp theo Ngọc Hà Bạn kia không
đặt tên là Khánh Hòa đâu
ý định lừa em nữa Ok bắt đầu nhé
Ừ đúng rồi chọi câu đúng sẽ ít
mà quan trọng là nhanh nhưng không nói
chuyện thôi 80 người rồi
anh vẫn thế mà thủ thuật bắt đầu nha à
có mười mấy câu gì vậy
ở
tại nhanh như con à
số 15 câu
3bán nhà ngồi nghĩ vào lúc đó chọn chưa
muốn cưới
sẽ được rồi trong lượng thế mà mười ông
cho argh LG lừa mày à
à à
anh nói AVG viết tắt của
Zen đời đúng không ạ
a a b c ở dễ lửa thôi
áo
kiểu nhiều người tôi tôi ghi rg Vì nhiều
người hiểu bị nhầm cái tóc của nói
a nhân 2 x 2
Ê
sexsy khỏi khó lắm nhỉ
Ngồi xem cũng đoán đúng được nghỉ sẽ làm
chơi thôi à
cho NaOH Silic gì đây
áo lót luôn là ở không rõ không chồng
ông ạ
đồng hồ Hello mọi người I
tư vấn mãn cuộc đời laptop kể
Ừ
anh không biết anh có thêm nó luôn rồi
nhưng mà cũng vài ông nhậu cũng rất buồn
cười
5 pro chị đếm số bản ghi bằng pp thôi
cao mẹ đúng không ạ
khi mình bắt tốt này ngon có khỉ tôi mở
máy và tôi bảo chứ cùng
anh
hứa không hẳn là nâng cao lắm chuyện
phía sau hơn thôi à
Ừ cái sách đề kiểm tra khi mày in shop
Thỏ iPad không ạ mình kiểm tra lại dữ
liệu
ô ồ tôi bứt tốp này ngon
lắm nhỉ
Ừ ông hủy bức chân tôi hả cái nhỉ Có dự
thật đó là thằng em tôi tên là Huy nhưng
mà nó sinh ra trước tôi mà em họ chị đã
xuất rồi và lúc đầu tên của tôi cũng lúc
đầu tôi mẹ tôi đặt tên cho nó vui đấy
nhưng vì nó xinh á trước nên nó được lấy
tên Huy tôi phải đặt tên lại long ở đây
tôi sẽ thích trong
ừ ừ
Ừ
cái này bên máy kia có ông họ đọc các
tài liệu của tôi sẽ biết à
Ừ cái sai nè Sai này là kiểu ký hiệu ấy
còn ăn sai là không ký hiệu còn trong
này nó hiểu là kiểu không có ký hiệu âm
mẹ không rõ lần trước anh chỉ được phép
không nổi lên thôi bên mãi queo có em
qua server không có
anh cho em tốt một cuối cùng đã lên là
số 1 ok
em yên tâm còn nhiều cái rất kỳ án II
ừ ừ
anh
không biết
Tôi không biết nói gì về đâu ạ tớ rõ ra
Phải ghi đấy Đấy là câu trả lời đúng rồi
mày nó không tin
lại kêu tôi lừa chỗ nào tôi cái đấy là
đáp án đúng tôi copy hẳn cái câu hỏi
mấy à
anh không biết nói gì
Ừ nếu không bảo tới lừa rồi nữa nhé mày
ông tự lừa bản thân mình thôi à
anh có giỡn thẳng tôi tra chị Google ra
là cái này rồi tôi copy hẳn cái về à
Anh không biết là buồn lắm
ở
những tự lửa mấy ông ấy chứ đúng không
3000 là bất em
mình đâu trợ nó vui rồi đấy rồi không
mất điện lên được à
em
không có sở liệu cơ mà mà không phải một
phê nếu mà ngôn ngữ lập trình mà nó Nói
chung nhiều lắm nó có tự nghĩ ra với ác
đấy
trong mày không giống câu cũng đâu
anh kể cái này nó lưu dữ liệu Cái Mơn
đấy nói nhanh hơn về mọi thứ để lưu dữ
liệu nằm ở đâu nghe về cơ bản giữ giọng
nói nhanh hơn
ở nhà nó khác câu hồi nãy
tin nhắn hay nhất 2
Em
muốn chọn nhé tập 30 giây cơ mà Tại sao
nó không chọn anh ấy Alo chọn xanh anh
thì không được điểm đâu ạ
ừ ừ
ở trường trung học quý giá thì Mỹ học gì
ạ phát ra cốc thôi Cái đôi ác tính bắt
buộc cho nên nó xuống chứ ạ
ừ ừ
có
một bảng có thể có nhiều cột chung một
khóa chính em mặc Quá chính vẫn là duy
nhất nóng lại cấu hình sinh viên Mình bị
nhầm nhiều hơn vì sinh viên mình thấy
bảng hóa đơn chi tiết và tận hai cột
hoặc là quá chính mình cứ tưởng à là 2
khóa chính không nói chuyện một khỏi
chúng tôi
Ừ thôi không được là gì cả bạn đã tìm
đúng nó lửa tên của tôi bay đâu mất rồi
đậu xanh à
Ừ
thôi mỗi bà đã bàn luôn đấy mà ông rộng
trượt Thôi anh nghỉ đi nhé
Mấy ông vẫn chọn thiệt thì cả đang kiểu
dữ liệu chúng em queo làm gì kiểu dữ
liệu email contact Khi nó dài quá cách
lưu đã quá dài lê văn bản không ạ Mà cha
Thôi chào và trai thôi
ca nhạc Đoạn Lê Thị mình bật đèn rồi ok
[âm nhạc]
chỉ còn 5 câu nữa của bất lên à
cha
mẹ mình có để bà già 50 rồi thoải mái ừ
em rửa ra ông Định lưu có dấu ở trong số
điện thoại flash với mình không được của
vì số điện thoại của mình là mình lưu
lại số không bằng đầu mà nó ngoan lên là
mất Hoặc ra đôi khi cộng 8842 gì đó thì
thì sẽ sẽ không được bạn ạ
Anh tên của mình lại beat
cho tôi đi cô tạ ok
ở lâu đài tình ái dâng cao phết
à à
Ừ cái này thì lỗi tôi rồi đấy tôi để nợ
nợ và trà chuẩn hơn là tách không đúng
lắm
Cho coi hình ở tôi vẫn chưa sửa để tôi
tôi
Em đừng có đúng ở câu này tôi chưa sửa
tối nốt lại quên chưa xin lỗi xin lỗi
địa chỉ nên navassa và thoải mái thôi
đời tách hơi hôm qua
Ừ Ừ tí tôi sẽ nốt lại là sữa Nếu không
biết còn gì vậy chơi không nữa Xin lỗi
Xin lỗi Xin lỗi cậu mày chắc là không
ảnh hưởng gì làm Đâu làm gì có mà bứt
lên
có đây à
ở tân cổ Bích lên hình này I
xin lỗi có phải lỗi rồi rồi Chắc không
sao đâu ông ấy bước lên một câu mà ăn
mai mày
em không ra còn mấy câu rỡ lại mà nhân
hay lại nhớ này
ừ ừ
Ừ
cái này là sworld.io nâng cao đây là nó
tôi đâu bảo là mỗi máy kéo đâu nghen sẽ
còn nợ tách nn gì đó à
ừ ừ
Ừ cái này
ở đồng hồ Cái này là tôi phải nói lại
mấy ông mà nó lại server Tôi đang hỏi
các bạn với bé cho server trong mãi mãi
que không
có bạn thì sẽ nhầm cả cái like như này
Ừ ừ đúng rồi các bạn Thể nhầm sang cả
cái like nhanh nữa
anh nói hơi muộn Nó hơi muộn thôi may
mắn nó những các bạn này mà đem đủ cho
các bạn này à
Vì cuộc đời là đối với phải không may
mắn ở đây đùn ép mày sinh nhật
Anh tên tôi bay xuống dưới rồi ôi tôi
cảm thấy bất may rồi Tại sao
anh
buồn quá
chủ nhân hay tiếp này cố lên
Vì
thế tôi bớt đi
bây giờ là kèo à
ừ ừ
ở ngoài cũng cắt cao phết
em coi Tân mà
anh không cần có thì đúng
em ở đâu không phải có thể chọn hơn nhà
không phải có thể chọn hơn
Ê hồi đấy mình đi mấy cái câu hỏi nó hơi
gây hiểu nhầm của tí nhỉ Không phải có
qua chị không cần có vậy cũng là không
cần có thì vẫn đúng vẫn tạo được bạn
không cần có khóa chính có
Ừ đúng rồi bạn không cần nhưng mà dùng
chứ không phải có thể nó sẽ hợp lý hơn
ạ Bây giờ tôi hỏi thế nào cho nữa thì
vẫn có người ở đúng là nó không ạ Chứng
tỏ là vẫn có ông đạt được ông Quý lên
trước này Tôi muốn kích trống hay quá có
khi ông Long ở ngay dưới tôi sẽ thích
ông y ông nóng được lên ý
à Cậu X2 biết coi không lửa đó gọi không
nè
anh alo Tôi không chắc luôn có phải như
lưu vào đấy mày không chọn nhanh nhé dài
cậu lại lừa tôi sẽ lo hết Như vậy
là
mình đã có à
chờ
đợi tí tôi chặn phong cách Spam nữa
Ừ ok Star purple
à à
ừ ừ
a a dirt et
vient et không phải in their TP ê
i
didn t t i
à à
có rất nhiều sinh viên tôi dính để mấy
giờ mèo cũng không biết ai sai đúng
không Thế thì để lỗi do mày ông rồi
Bộ Công an rất hay điểm có lý do đó cả
mà mấy cũng chẳng tỉ cả để nhầm rồi
à quất tốt này tôi muốn ký kiwi quá đỗ
sai
tên tôi rồi
em có quấy
ừ ừ
các bạn nhà buồn quá à
Ừ rồi
chị xem xem ai người ở tốt nhé Vợ ông
Huy cũng buồn lắm à
em đi rồi này cái nhỉ
Ừ đúng là lừa Đúng là lừa như là đeo
thôi thì lấy
Lâu Đài Tình Ái Cậu cũng đi ông ơi E với
ạ
khi
nãy các bạn hạnh phúc vui cho vui nhon
hi hiểu nào nhỉ à
họ đậu xanh
vì em đã lời bản thân nên mới cao tơ
được cái Lừa của anh Ok em
Đúng rồi Thật ra hồi đấy à mình cho cứ
sau cứ mỗi một buổi học của mình sao cho
cá mút mình quên cho các bạn chơi đấy
nhưng mà hồi đấy Mình phải soạn cáo hút
nữa cơ
mình các bạn quen là mình thức ra mấy
cái vụ mình dậy xong cho các bạn à Mình
cũng cho các bạn chưa trách nhiệm mà
chẳng qua nó không có cạnh tranh bằng
cái kéo hút này thôi nhưng mình cho các
bạn chơi cách trắc nghiệm mà nhớ không ạ
Ê mày cấm trắc nghiệm về tội nghĩ nát nó
phải ra đấy thôi chứ nếu mà tôi cho cái
trắc nghiệm đấy theo kiểu livestream
kiểu như này như cá hút thì được ra là
các bạn có về vẫn vui hơn nữa ngọn
Ừ nhưng mà ở Đáng lẽ tôi phải làm như
thế thu quên mất đấy
tôi đã cho mình cái trách nhiệm đấy ở
trên cái Trang Te cái bồ đấy các bạn
nhiều không ạ Có nhiều cái tôi phải cố ý
nghĩ nó hay hài hài cô câu hỏi hài mà có
câu trả lời cũng lừa đã ạ
khi nghe đại cái gì à à
để dễ nhớ thì ra là một chuyện nói chung
mà các bạn ạ thì
các bạn thấy hào hứng học tập rồi các
thứ
xong rồi phải theo được cái nghề nữa
không ạ ạ
ở ngã ở dưới cách đứng dậy ở dưới cơ à
anh em thể vào cái cái cái bồ cũng có
cái bài tập đúng cách cái sau mấy em trả
lời trắc nghiệm được cho vui
à à
ở
sông à Bây giờ
Bây giờ mình định cho các bạn tâm sự
giao lưu thêm một tí nữa rồi mình kết
thúc các bạn còn có hỏi thắc mắc gì
không ạ Nói chung là như mình thông báo
nhé Mà tí mình sẽ đăng thông báo lại lên
cho bạn nào mà hôm nay không ngon đó là
như mình thông báo thì hôm nay mình sẽ
Ừ
bắt đầu từ thứ bảy tuần sau thì mình sẽ
livestream nhưng mà livestream là để mà
Chữa bài tập cũng như là chấm chấm bay
gần nhau chấm bài ngoạn sẽ chia sẻ những
cái bài của các bạn đồ án các bạn
ở nơi nào đến like đưa sẽ lùi xa nhà thứ
bay để cho chủ nhật mình à dành cho hả
đúng có một ngày được nghỉ ạ bởi vì mình
làm việc mấy ngày trong tuần cũng căng
phết rồi
Cô gái có một sự thật là thứ bảy chủ
nhật mình vẫn làm cái này nó bị kiểu
không có ngày nghỉ mà mình mình không
quan tâm mình đã từng nói các bạn đó là
thực ra mình cứ sáng dậy sáng dậy đã
ngồi máy tính rồi đến khi ở ngủ thì mới
không ngồi nữa Thế nên là ngày nào mình
cũng vừa làm rồi
Ừ nhưng mà nghĩa là không không nên để
dồn hết việc là thứ thứ Bảy Chủ Nhật thì
nó căng quá Thế mình nghĩ à Thứ Bảy là
bây giờ cũng hết thứ này mà dậy rồi tuần
sau mình sẽ
chuyển qua những cải lương cao tí phí
chắc là mình lại tạo facebook đi mình sẽ
tạm một cái gốc ở một cái trang nào đó
có cái Trang hôm trước mình mới biết là
có cái trang tạo Ghost dành cho lập
trình viên để mà nên làm những tính năng
gì mình sẽ thử tạo cái vuốt từ đấy rồi
cho mọi người vào được để vuốt xem lại
mình sẽ nên mình sẽ tuần sau mình sẽ dậy
những tính năng gì đó để mà các bạn các
nhóm nào mà cảm thấy thích làm tính năng
nào nhất thì mình sẽ demo dậy các bạn
những tính năng đấy để ngoạn thì nó sẽ
khá Công Bằng
A và mình sẽ trao mình sẽ dạy các bạn về
một tí record có thử nữa nếu mà nhóm làm
thấy ổn Nói chung là đấy à Dậy ở một
chuyện thôi các bạn cũng không biết các
bạn đã làm xong hết rồi chưa để mà áp
dụng vào có khi là có nhóm bây giờ vẫn
chỉ xong tương đối mới đến một nửa thì
chưa nhảy sang nâng cao được
Nghe danh sách nhóm bảo vệ đợt 2 mình cứ
tạm Chốt vào ngày mùng 1 tháng 1 thì
mình bắt đầu xếp nhóm cũng có khá nhiều
bạn đăng ký rồi
a a đấy mình quên chưa Để Linh ở đăng ký
tra để cuối video này mình sẽ bình luận
được Linh đăng ký cho video này
cả những video trước nữa quên đi
Ông Hà ông ông cúi khô rồi ông Block vào
bình luận hội tôi phát cái link đăng ký
vào trong mấy cái video trước này cho
các bạn là người bạn xem sau mấy bạn đấy
đăng ký Linh đúng ạ
e8aa Huy quên đấy Ok nhé Mình ở đợi thì
tôi chỉ không tính tiền
ờ ờ
ừ ừ
Ỷ
Lợi tí tôi sạc cái
xào cà chua của tôi chuột không dây nhau
là phải cắm sạc
à à
em bận quá không đăng ký được ạ
Alo Alo
bận bận quá không đăng ký được thì ra
hơi khó nhỉ à
cho tôi mượn này tôi bận mà chưa dậy các
bạn xong chưa đủ bây giờ còn phải chấm
mại nữa mệt vãi
không Mình không làm về nốt ghét thì
nhảy sang bên view luôn ra quan hệ xong
đi luôn à
à à
anh
lại phải như thế Mình vừa nghĩ vợ thông
báo các bạn khá nhiều thứ ở đúng hạn các
bạn có thắc mắc gì được không ạ
ở trên cái cái bồ thì mình không trả
tiền nên nó không nó không gửi cho mình
cái thống kê những ai đã làm bà ấy cũng
như không cho một người chỉ làm một lần
nữa thì ngay các bạn làm kia hợp đúng
thì thôi cũng được
ở tầm thời gian nào bắt đầu thuyết trình
thực ra thì như mình đã dậy các bạn như
thế này thì chả tuần sau mình sẽ cũng
tuần này và tuần sau cho mình sẽ kiểm
tra hết đầy đủ tính năng thêm sữa xóa
thậm chí là tuần sau nữa thì có thể nói
chung là xong bên giỏ hàng lại cảm biến
hóa đơn thì tuần sau nữa thì bao lâu
Kiểm tra tài liệu nói chung ngoài cũng
phải tầm hơn Khánh nữa Hơn tháng nữa làm
là chừng ấy
vì nghe lệnh anh ấy đúng ạ Cho qua tết
nha quà tết mình sẽ bắt đâu thế Chị bảo
vệ đồ án
Ừ để định một còn đợt 2 thì cho là sẽ
khác không ạ
Anh ở trường mình có nghĩa mới sinh viên
không ạ Mình không biết là mình có nhiên
hay không Bởi vì thực ra mình cũng nhớ
lúc mình nọ mình mặn gắt mà bọn nó vẫn
kiểu cần chè bởi vì đã bởi vì mình đùa
chơi Bọn nó nhiều quá vẫn cửa nhà Tết âm
sau tới âm chứ còn tới giường thì sinh
năm nay nữa
Ừ cái này cái bảo vệ đồ này mình thấy là
các bạn nên mới nếu mà muốn theo ngày
này các bạn phải rất là nghiêm túc với
nó bởi vì cái này mới thể hiện việc các
bạn có phù hợp với cái ngành các bạn
đang chọn này không nó còn hơn ngày thi
cử mình mình nói thật là tôi k còn hơn
cả thì cựu trên giường thi cử trường nó
là điểm số nó không quyết định cái gì cả
cái bằng cấp bây giờ nó không quyết định
cái gì cả cái thứ để mà chứng minh được
xem mình có phù hợp hay không ạ Nó là
những cái kiểu bảo vệ đồ án làm cái đồ
án sau đó thì thuyết trình kiểu như này
mình tin là như thế
a màu tím như thế hơn là cái lý thuyết
kiểu chiến trường dậy à
Ừ mình dậy trên trường cái gì à mình dậy
chiến trường đúng như những cái mình
đánh dậy các bạn luôn nó dụng cả việc
cao hút làm bài tập và các thứ bài tập
mệnh chia sẻ cả các bạn đúng như thế
Anh bảo quy trình bảo vệ đồ án thì mình
sẽ sẽ chia sẻ ở
gần khi gần đến bảo vệ thì mình sẽ chia
sẻ các bạn quy trình bảo vệ đoán các
chương trình như thế nào sau A
Ừ
đúng rồi là thuyết trên mình đã làm
những cái gì tài liệu các thứ
ạ sau một môn học thường có cái đồ án là
cái sản phẩm để tổng hợp kiến thức môn
học đúng đúng đúng đúng mày còn nói đúng
đấy ạ
Ê Linh Linh cũng rồi không cần thay đổi
thì cả đúng không ạ
à à
Ừ thôi vợ bạn lại gần hai tiếng rồi mình
à mình xin phép hôm nay tập kết thúc đây
Những cái có họ và những cái tâm sự hãy
các thứ chưa Mình chưa tổng hợp tìm được
thì buổi sao mình sẽ trả lời nhé
không mình không dễ k12
bạn kia chắc là ở trường cũng mình mình
không còn dậy ở cho trường nữa mà không
ạ
Thôi tạm chào các bạn nhé có gì thì lại
bình luận hỏi đáp thì mình sẽ tổng hợp
cho buổi trao trả lời sau
à à